we have new merch for sale we haven't
done merch for a while because I was
weirded out by the trash garbage that a
lot of these companies make we finally
found a company that makes one uh that
is the real deal okay look at look at
this horse merch what more could you
want in life get it for your girlfriend
your boyfriend your mom your dad your
friend or any weirdos who love wearing
clothes with animals on them aka the
people that like to sit alone at parties
and not be talked to this is a great way
to get people to be like I don't I'm not
even gonna
yeah I'll let them come to me I promise
that if you have a hoarder in your life
you can't seem to find the perfect
Taxidermy statue for the new good for
you merch will do the trick amazing
quality no children lost fingers or got
Cobalt poisoning during the making of it
you will receive your sweatshirt your
long shirt your short sleeve shirt
you're getting about four weeks
completely free of children's tears or
fingernails the merch is not Chinese
trash just the perfect top if you're
white trash
today's guest is comedian Kathy Griffin
Don't Panic it's not going to be a big
libtard Festival uh even though I don't
even know if I'm liberal at this point
like liberals went so far off the cliff
that I feel like I'm like in the middle
now I'm like
you guys do we need to offer manicures
to Boys in kindergarten like we're first
period like does that need to be a part
of the curriculum I mean I don't know
maybe I wait you guys want to get rid of
squirt guns because it's toxic
masculinity I'm lost
you want me to ask my unborn baby it's
gender and if it wants to transition in
utero
I guess I'm not liberal anymore
I'm I'm just confused anyway luckily
none of this stuff comes up she has so
much wisdom she's insanely resilient
interesting uh insights on what makes us
unlikable likable lots of interesting
Showbiz stuff she's learned a lot about
when to bite your tongue and when not
I really hope I learned something from
this Joy Kathy Griffin
action action coming in hot does that
does hearing action make you kind of I
make him do that because then I'm like I
make I like action in almost any
scenario where I'm even half working
like seriously like I've been in
situations where I've had my friends say
action to order from you know McDonald's
I respond I'm a lights up performer I'm
so pavlovian like I was working with
this trainer a while back and I was like
when you need me to do something can you
just say action yeah because I know that
I'll like become the show Pony that
means what 15 reps yeah okay it's like
I'll just know that's what I need to
turn on yeah you know all right can we
talk about your pregnancy sure okay so I
I want to address the can I break the
fourth wall like Moonlighting please of
course okay good so I went to visit
Whitney's animals because I wanted some
animal therapy and because Whitney was
no help at all but thank God for an
alpaca which was actually an emu but
she's not educated in a traditional way
anyway it was a giraffe for the first
like 35 famous and that is a pass and so
I saw her picture on Instagram Michael
Jackson Neverland okay so I I
um thought that you had posted a picture
with a distended stomach as a bitch when
I visited you you had a shirt tucked in
jeans and I swear you were not showing
so I go home and I say to the husband I
told you it was a bit it was a bitch
she's not pregnant and he's like why do
you think that I go she didn't even
mention it like it didn't even come so I
feel like an asshole but I didn't even
congratulate you on your bit
which is now going to be a precious
angel from heaven the worst part is that
you didn't think the bit was funny at
least I thought it was a solid bitch not
your best bitch but I thought it was
solid I thought it was solid I was two
months pregnant when I found out okay
are you that's that's like a TLC show
that is it is that's I Didn't Know I Was
Pregnant which by the way please bring
that back because I know TLC never
misses this podcast which here would
what I will say is touring in
Saskatchewan Canada is the same symptoms
as being pregnant okay I was like
nauseous I was tired you know I have a
double tonight yeah it's actually
exactly and I didn't really I was eating
out of vending machines and I was like
didn't you notice weren't you nauseous I
was like yeah I was in Saskatchewan yeah
you know that's how we roll there yeah
so I just kind of like didn't put it
together and then she was like you have
a full baby and you I was like
wild I'm just wrapping my head around
full as an adjective
that is a load off my mind I mean I
don't know about you I got pregnant
naturally at 40. like I'm convinced it's
a vaccine injury like I don't even it's
side effects I'm like this I got the job
Johnson yeah I don't know I heard you
got pregnant from Ivermectin that's
what's going around on Tick Tock
so yeah so it's it's I'm being very
awkward about it because I also feel
like when I feel like when women get
pregnant they always act like they're
the first person to ever get pregnant
and I don't want to be one of those
people so I just like do these people
like are you pregnant I'm like yeah no
we don't need to talk about it like
let's just see we're not there yet we
haven't crossed the finish line yet
let's just not you know how many kids
did your mom have how many siblings two
okay that's that I'm I'm Irish Catholic
that's bullshit two my mother and this
is a fact my dear departed mother was
the youngest of 16.
so imagine going through this
16 times I don't you know why because
the Lord baby Jesus
told them to just you he hated them
hated them and resented them very much
did they all get along I mean that's
like no he's such an Irish like it was
such a um Frank McCourt book that is
that the ripe in court I know there's
two I don't know oh you know the
Angela's Ashes it was such that book
that they weren't even alive at the same
time like wild and a couple of them died
in like old-timey Irish Catholic ways
like it was just so are you gonna set
yourself on fire no I heard that was
your thing I heard that you're like if
the podcast isn't going well I didn't
like myself igniting it's never gotten
old so just be safe dude whatever hair
extensions I put in today do smell weird
so I do want to get that candle I think
this is the old Jessica Simpson ones
remember the ones who couldn't
yes but wait so that is a lot of the
reason why people used to have so many
kids was in case some died you had
enough to run the farm yeah was it did
you come from farming stuff we came from
drinking stock sure and drink a lot and
then I will say my grandparents came
over on the boat steerage oh which means
because my grandparents were born there
if Trump gets elected again I think
there's some shady way I could get Irish
dual citizenship although I don't know
what I would realistically do in Ireland
for four years but it's beautiful I
visited there once it was gorgeous but I
do like thinking I have an Exit Plan and
Canada won't take me I tried really yeah
I tried to buy a house in Canada and
there was so much Miss gosh and
sometimes I talk like I'm Jewish I'm not
I'm into it I could pass it I just found
it on half Jewish in December I know and
you have a full baby and a full baby so
how how Jewish is the baby
half of a half or I don't if I'm the I
guess if you're the mother the baby
Jewish have you in therapy at all dug
into ancestral trauma stuff like yes
deep Ireland the stuff we carry the
guilt the shame the unfinished business
because I think about the guilt my poor
grandmother must have had and by the way
I was only alive for one grandparent
they were all died off by the time I was
born because I'm going to call an
accident baby I do what they call me a
surprise
oh yeah and then when they realized I
was brunette they were really bummed oh
boy yeah like there's too much surprise
because I'm 13 months younger than my
older sister oops yeah I know yeah but
when you're an accident and I know a lot
of people a lot of people that were the
youngest yeah were yep fine you kind of
know yeah I feel like I knew at a very
young age I'd earn my keep I felt like I
stressed my mom I felt like there wasn't
enough room for me and I had to kind of
shape-shift and you know make myself a
chameleon in order to fit in yeah I knew
at a very early age like I have to be
entertaining I have to be fun I have to
be needless I have to be self-contained
I have to be an overachiever I have to
be perfect I can't add any stress I
remember so vividly going up to my dad
and he was always watching SNL always
watching you know comedy yeah I think
part of the reason I was like I need to
get in the Box yeah that time to get him
to see me and I went up to him and I
remember saying like Hey Dad and then he
was like Hey and I remember thinking
that didn't go well
I remember thinking regroup try a
different approach you were bombing and
saying hello 100 yeah and I remember
going like that didn't go well and then
the next time I was like hey Daddy like
that was it yeah no I I think that's why
I'm a performer as well also both my
parents worked full-time so I was also
what's called a latchkey kid yep so
coming home from school let myself in
watch a little something called the
after school special you're trying to
make yourself lunch thank you the whole
thing
um oh I also had an eating disorder
which means even at that age I would get
a Jiffy cake and they used to make like
a cake for one
Jiffy Frosting mix it up and I would
have yellow cake with chocolate frosting
and I would buy a can of Pringles
because they were new and revolutionary
at the time and we thought they were
potato chips not potato crisps like I
don't even know if there's any potatoes
and Pringles but probably and that would
be my salty sweet thing and then I was
so wrecked that I would take the garbage
from it I didn't barf but I would take
the garbage and go to like the
neighbor's garbage can so my mom
wouldn't see the Jiffy box when she got
home because mom came home first I know
when did you know when you had that you
had a disordered eating no I think and
what's funny is I didn't have the kind
because I wanted to be thin I just had
an an overeating disorder and so I
wasn't a purger I was just an overeader
and then I would starve myself but it
still was like the same and I think I
just was lonely and this was my friend
and like I said in front of the TV you
know the schedule was like I think I
used to watch like Peyton Place like if
that was even still on when I was in
grade school but like I remember having
my shows and looking forward to and me I
was you know bored and frustrated in
school school I didn't love school
except the social aspect yeah if you
have a quick mind school is just I
rarely had classes that I even was like
excited about I was terrible doing
homework I used to watch TV till two in
the morning every night and fantasize
about being on TV and like you said in
the box and obsessed like and then
obsessively wanting to be the sidekick I
didn't want to be the pretty girl I was
like the pretty girl is great share
names on the title but the sidekick tell
us that that's where that's all the cute
clothes
Phyllis Ethel I know I always wanted to
be Janet from Three's Company yeah you
know like I was going to be Mrs Roper
I'm just saying I was 10. so it's
interesting I'm hearing like do you feel
like not a lot of people talk about
neglect and I'm not accusing anyone I'm
neglecting it just sort of I had a mom
that worked a lot I'm glad I got to see
her work ethic I know I absorbed a lot
of it it didn't even occur to me that
you didn't work a bunch of jobs by the
way at the minute you could so why got
the workers permit at 15 had a job in a
local store and on 16 I was like I don't
even need a permit so yeah a hundred
percent our family was like the minute
you're 15 you get a job somewhere did
you feel like the eating was like a
loneliness thing yeah I lived straight
up filling the void like quite literally
I just and also like I was a McDonald's
kid yep like I I don't know if you were
breastfed but my mother believed in
something called Similac
and it's a powdery substance that I
believe one puts with water and it was
just what does tips on your nail I don't
know
shellac and I guess I just she just put
it in the bottle and I was a Similac
baby and so I really only knew junk food
honestly until I was like 18 or 20. I
didn't I your tolerance for sugar was
probably really high and because they
both worked it was here's a dollar go to
McDonald's and you could get a whole
meal for 95 cents or whatever and so our
family was like a big sweets family my
mom didn't cook so for when we had a
rare family dinner which because they
both worked was maybe Sundays maybe once
a week and she made hamburger helper so
my birthday would be Hamburger Helper
and a Betty Crocker cake for my birthday
and she would make a lemon cake with
lemon frosting but I didn't even know
there was a way to make a cake that
wasn't a mix like I thought the mix was
scratch right right I didn't know some
ladies the the dumb ones breastfed and
made cakes from flour and others whores
they were dirty whores and so yeah so
that was my that was it Similac they
still make it we'll see this is it
Similac Total Care infant formula with
prebiotics see what's the closest
formula to breast milk they're not even
like it's similar this is our closest I
can top it please my mother would get
hammered on her box of wine and then she
used to Pride herself on saying and
those goddamn doctors when I was
pregnant with you Kathleen
they gave me speed to keep my weight
down and that's why you're like this
that's what's wrong with you
and by the way she was being honest that
that piece of shit doctor used to give
women speed to try to like not have them
not have baby fat wow so my mom was like
a speed freak when she was pregnant and
that's what's wrong with me and that's
why I'm wrong in his speed
is speed like amphetamines oh yeah the
fact that like is like what Adderall
would be today yes and they would just
by the way I don't know like if it was
even more powerful than Adderall or less
but yeah it would be like taking
over the I mean Street speed like
amphetamines
like doll says they used to call them in
value that I was like yeah it was like
what became like black beauties or
speckled eggs or right right I don't
even know how what you call it these
days but I would just yeah it's
definitely at the time that was just
like a vitamin or like yeah it was like
part of the regiment the prenatal care
and it's crazy to think because I
remember I have you know friends whose
mom's like Oh yeah we were encouraged to
smoke while we were pregnant because it
would calm us down it would help us take
deep breaths and it would you know so I
always think like what are the things
we're doing today yeah then in 30 years
we're gonna look back and go like like
what am I doing right now iPhones
iPhones yep I mean it's gonna be someday
they're gonna go what were you thinking
you didn't know phones could kill it's
gonna be something where people are
going to be appalled what's happened to
the stories that were everywhere and I
you know remember watching Oprah's about
this entire Oprah's where if you held
your phone up here too much you got
cancer that was a big thing for years
like people going on 60 Minutes like
that kind of went away RFK used to
defend them he I mean he I I I'm not
getting into his I don't know enough
about it but he uh as a lawyer I'll talk
about him as a lawyer yeah as a
candidate uh defended a lot of people in
those exact cases talking about yeah
exactly
but I don't know what happened to that
so either they were just wrong or they
or they bought their way out of it yeah
and then I've got this strap that I
carry my phone around on a strap at all
times yes because I feel like I'm always
going to lose it yeah and so it just
hits right on my uterus okay well that's
um it's just banging up against your
uterus yeah so by the way Jesse Jesse's
here my attache can you go online and
find that strap because I have one a
strap for my phone but it's too weak and
it like falls off I actually might have
one yeah to borrow in the meantime this
is bandolier and it's got my credit
cards in it it's this whole everyone
makes fun of me but yeah it's just my
phone yeah and then also it sometimes
when you have to take a photo and you
don't have anything to put it on yeah
you can turn it upside down hang it on
something and then take the phone oh
yeah so it kind of doubles as a tripod
sometimes I'll be in venues if I need to
take like a kind of work video I'll just
hang it in the back you know on a mic
stand or something and you can video oh
hey y'all so last week you probably
noticed that we did a big merch drop of
sweatshirts that have horses on it and
you're thinking how could Whitney a
person who almost exclusively wears
clothes
from thrift stores and gas stations with
horses on it who does the hahas and the
hihis for a living who spends most of
her time arguing with male comedians
know how to work such a high-tech merch
business is she some kind of Genius did
she have her robot do it is she having
an affair with the CEO of the internet
what Gibbs I'll tell you what gives
Shopify when we were launching the new
merch and had to set up the way to sell
it I almost gave up y'all I almost went
to pigeons I was like yes pigeons you
get all this is terrifying to me let's
just give it to a pigeon they'll fly
we'll put a little laser beam on them I
don't know
I'm pretty much great at putting a
design of a horse on a thing and picking
the fabric when it comes to how the
pixels talk to the ones and the zeros
I got nothing y'all but I was quickly
calmed down by my web guy going hey
idiot we're gonna be using Shopify to
sell your merch Shopify is the Commerce
platform revolutionizing millions of
businesses worldwide and now I know why
after using it last week it's a dream no
tricks no scams where it makes you use
zip files or geocities or some Madness
whether you're a garage entrepreneur or
an IPO ready Shopify is the only tool
you will need to start run and grow your
business without the struggle Shopify
puts you in control of every sales
channel so whether you're selling satin
sheets from shopify's in-person POS
system or offering organic olive oil on
shopify's all-in-one e-commerce platform
you're covered I don't know why I keep
burping sorry and once you've reached
your audience Shopify has the internet's
best converting checkout to help you
turn them from browsers to buyers
Shopify Powers 10 of all e-commerce in
the US and Shopify is truly a global
Force powering all birds Roth these and
Brooklyn and now dork Rodeo which is
what I've decided to call the good for
you line
changed my mind and millions of other
entrepreneurs of every size over 170
countries I didn't even know there were
that many countries plus shopify's
award-winning help is there to support
your success every step of the way sign
up for a dollar per month trial period
at shopify.com Whitney all lower case
that's a dollar a month that's insane go
to shopify.com Whitney to take your
business to the next level today
shopify.com slash Whitney Do It Go Get
Rich the easy way wait can I just do my
own horn please because I I'm sorry
someone told me a story
but I'm just gonna be really corny and
touch me and it's gonna sound like an
asshole because she should be telling
the story about me which would be cool
but I can't
so I never really met Melissa McCarthy
even though we were both in the
Groundlings I was just in at a different
a much earlier era and I didn't even
know she was the girl from the growlings
at first I just thought she was an
actress then I found out she was in the
growlings which is a comedy improv group
here in Los Angeles and I cycled through
there and I got to work with like Phil
Hartman like I got to work with some
amazing people and then I was there for
a long time and stuff like that so
anyway I see her yesterday at a party it
was kind of a big party so I didn't want
to like monopolize her but we were just
chatting for a minute and I finally I go
you're you were growlings right and
she's like Kathy the first growling show
I ever even went to they were doing an
improv about a shirtless gym and the
guys took their shirts off and then
later in the scene you burst in with
your shirt off from the door and it got
this giant laugh because you had this
like silly bra and whatever but she goes
I went I want to be her and I signed up
for the classes Monday
and I was like what
and then I said can you maybe tell that
story in 60 minutes would that kill you
so I'm just going to tell you that story
because I am very much owning I'm 62
years young and I am owning I'm trying
to step into my grand Dom phase of my
love it right I love it so next is the
mumus
um I think I could because of my age I
think I can get away with a lot of
politically inappropriate stuff yes like
I can have like gay boys and neckties
you can actually do like whatever you
want right yeah I'm thinking like um
turman's yes maybe
um I can have like an eyelash on my
cheek by mistake a bindi oh you have a
cut on your face yes
you should have a Stigmata right no one
will care I I have already started this
when I go to a restaurant I can't help
but call the servers hun and honey oh
sweet peas I'm already sweet pea I'm
already there okay and color contacts
color contacts would be great like a
like a lilac knee highs
with a nice comfortable sandal with a
sandal with like a like a goatee
Bejeweled sandal very like a low chunky
here Betsy Johnson because honey I can't
do those that pitch anymore like you
young gals I can't be pitching my feet
in five inch heels those days oh no I
don't I want a low Chunk in a lot of it
ended when I bought a house and I can I
can also over jewelry you can do
anything
earrings necklace
several Rings maybe even like a uh what
do you call when you're gonna punch
somebody like um
knuckles I could do brass knuckles yeah
with my name on them oh yes cause you're
a brassy maybe what if it's time for me
to go from Kathy to kitty
kitty Griffin well then we're Griffin at
the Mirage in Las Vegas one night only
can I tell you Katie Griffin Kitty is
really working by the way Kitty gets to
do whatever she wants wants and like if
I'm in the diapers and there's leakage
too so what I'm Kitty so that's how
kitty is Kitty leaks so what she's been
through this the middle oh she's been in
so many rodeos she forgot to count Katie
was literally breading a puppy mill
Kitty was raised on speeds that her
mommy took and her mommy was the
youngest of 16. give Kitty a break
do you like how I make my grandmother's
issues my own well I have no children
it's one thing it's your grandma should
I get that thank you it's not one thing
it's your mom do you have any more
advice for Kitty
I feel like kitty if we're going from
Kathy to Kitty I don't know about the
mumus I think we're at capes oh I think
we're in full capes okay okay the moo
moo mate your housekeeper can do the
movement maybe but if we're in Kitty
territory I feel like we're collecting
dolls yeah oh and then I get in that
Demi Moore Mafia yeah and Marie Osmond
they're both doll people really and no
the best is when you'll see them
photographed at a doll Mafia convention
and they're real there's a real Mafia
and they always have them in like
Ottumwa Iowa and Demi Moore is there
looking like the youngest person a tum
was ever seen and Marie isn't far behind
going because Bernie's got the crazy
laugh She's Not Afraid of good time you
know Marie nope and when Kitty and Marie
and Demi and I get together and we're
gonna share a hotel room yep yep we're
gonna go to multiple we're gonna do a
doll tour you you guys are in the twin
bed the dolls are in the king that's
right we name them oh of course you name
it after our lovers
so for me it's like that guy I banged it
in sync I won't name names but it wasn't
Lance I can tell you that and no one
knows the names of anyone else well
that's I know that's kind of true
a Chris kill Martin wait okay no that's
Karen kick out
um uh Joey Fatone Lance Bass Tyler
Perry was he in there I don't know any
of them think about it I don't know I
forgot that one record Frozen Saint Gary
um this is making me very happy I feel
here's the only problem is that
everything I want to pitch you is almost
not as crazy as what I'm already doing
I'm like what if you collect something
like my little ponies uh yeah what's
what's the issue behind those because
there is one there is uh this is stuff
that fans send Okay um I say stuff that
I like liked as a kid do you talk to
them well the fans are the no I I know
you don't talk to fans
I know you've been known to strike them
physically when you don't like the way
they look at you anyway instead of the
eye line honey but do you talk to your
toy horses I don't talk to my toy horses
that might actually be healthy yeah it
might actually be cathartic oh kitty
talks to her plants good kitty talks to
The Ficus well because you know plants
do talk to each other also so you might
as well join right that's right in fact
Kitty's in show tunes I feel like kitty
I I'm really into what Kitty collects
yeah
um she likes Old Town like old-fashioned
Miami memorabilia I feel like she's got
a couple Jane Seymour paintings yeah
yeah he loves paints George Bush yeah
she's got a couple of the dogs I'd
rather I'd so rather have the Jane
Seymour paintings maybe she like got the
painting of Bill Clinton
no it's not gonna happen not in Kitty's
lifetime does Kitty have a QVC line yes
eyeliner on one side like eye shadow on
the other yeah but it's it's for mature
ladies so it's like a robot system
because you know we get shaky sure it's
shaky and leaky and so it's like a robot
system by the way like a jitterbug it
has one button so don't worry kitties
fans don't have to like figure it out or
read instructions no thanks so it's a
robot that puts the makeup for you on
for you and there's a music playlist and
it's also show tunes with a little like
greatest hits of Jim Nabors yep like
it's got some fan favorites it's got the
Ethel Merman disco album did you know
that there's a channel that's just Bob
Ross painting
it's him painting just 24 hours straight
I feel like she may be that's on her
Samsung yeah painting TV she fucked Bob
Ross twice of course and everybody knows
the second time she was drunk on a
martini because it takes so little with
Kitty he actually used to do her makeup
I'm also too fat to be Kitty and I'm
only about 110 pounds the Kitty's got to
come in at about 87. okay you know how
those old Dames get so thin you don't
even know how they stand but for some
reason they're incredible at tennis yeah
they like she never misses her tennis
lessons you know so there's some kind of
uh there's a pill there's a pill there's
well there's always a pill with Kitty
there's a there's a peptide I feel like
it's an injection and there's a pet pill
I feel like there's there's a freezer in
the in the garage she's got illegal stem
cells that's it right that's it yeah um
I think she's got an invention going and
some kind of visor that turns into a
mirror to do your makeup it has a fan on
the side yeah you know yeah you can be
out
she calls it the everything and it's
just everything it's called the
everything and it's a mirror and it's a
fan and it talks to you and it plays
songs and it puts your makeup on for you
and that's how kitty just spends the
first now it does take four hours but
who what else are you doing what else
are you doing who doesn't want to relax
and listen to time in between writing
thank you thank you exactly and never
misses I feel like thank you the desk of
thank you notes yeah I feel like stamps
right and it says from the desk of kitty
from the desk of kitty and a lot of
these letters are going to where there's
uh going to give feedback on Services
some companies yes but also service from
the last party she went to so she's also
connected with the Vanderbilts and the
Rockefellers and the duponts she knows
that whole crowd so it's like dear
Alicia Dupont what you have done with
the sun room is utter stunning like it's
just a lot of complimentary you know so
it's most as incredible as how many
chemicals you yeah put into the Apple
apps
right yeah is I feel like she her best
friend is like her like dental assistant
yeah she's got like a best friend it's
not hairs too it would be like a young
Debbie Rowe like whoever is the plastic
surgeon's assistant who also is
available to give her eggs to a random
let's just go with asexual celebrity
right right what are her super by the
way who's asexual these days like who's
been asexual since Michael Jackson
remember that was the whole thing with
him like he's just he's not gay straight
he's asexual was that his thing yeah
that wasn't his like real right right it
wasn't his thing thing yes yes but it
was just the face of his Empire have I
told this story on the podcast show me
asexual no I feel like he always says
he's Timothy Charlemagne yeah I mean
with that chin he better looks like a
chicken let's just be honest I think
there's an effeminization of a lot of
actors but I always wonder though I'm
always going like where has this
happened before he reminds me a lot and
he is doing the um uh not Charlie
Chaplin uh Willy Wonka Willy Wonka yeah
he's um uh Johnny Depp was like that
though yeah uh Leonardo DiCaprio was
like but the thinness is what makes him
so fashion forward like he's so skinny
like a model yeah he can wear chick
clothes or dude clothes right off the
Runway I just think we had like a window
of actors that looked like men you'd
actually well just we had Seth Rogen we
had um uh Jason Siegel for a minute
there we had just guys that looked I was
playing with Daniel Craig but okay okay
you know I just mean like guys that just
looked like you know human beings and
now we're back to like cyborg he's a
wife pourless is still appropriate yeah
he's a wife and I think there's a
androgyny yeah
um I I in androgyny versus asexual I
don't really know the difference
um no xiaomi is not asexual he's not
trying to even right yeah like I think
Andrew he's like he's like with a lot of
chicks so I call guys like that horse
because they've called us whores for so
long I love calling guys whores
this show is brought to you by
betterhelp therapy y'all I'm telling you
I normally talk about why therapy is so
helpful and how I'm in it and how much
it's helped me but this episode I'm
going to tell you about how I went
without it for four weeks
um and let me tell you it was a mistake
I because you get to a certain stage
where you're going to therapy regularly
your life starts to get better you start
to get sane or things start to get
clearer and then you're like I got this
dude I got it it's fine I'm busy I'm
gonna be out of town I'm gonna have
sketchy Wi-Fi at the hotel
let me tell you two weeks no therapy
texted two x's
one of them on WhatsApp
Shady okay I agreed to do two podcasts
what I had already set the boundary that
I'm going to take the rest of the year
off of doing other people's podcasts
until I'm promoting my special next year
so check me out on those uh Rick lastman
and trash Tuesday coming out soon
and Pat where are we where
so I skipped therapy for four weeks do
you want to just put in the Rick
Glassman trash Tuesday thing yeah I had
skipped therapy for four weeks because I
was like I got this I'm Healed what's a
month off cut to me buying a Nirvana
shirt in Urban Outfitters so the reason
it's important is I already have 10
Nirvana shirts second
I literally without talking to a
therapist every week started regressing
into being a teenager like emotionally
therapy keeps me and my adult right
because like people talk about your
inner child coming out and you know
having a histrionic reaction because
you're inner child people don't talk
about your inner teenager my therapist
taught me about this when you're being
petulant or you're you know have some
kind of
activated reaction to somebody and it
might be an authority figure a lot of
times that's your inner teenager right
or inner teenager comes out so my inner
teenager was like I don't want to work I
don't want to do this you know I mean I
guess I was pregnant as a teenager so
maybe that's why I don't know I'm
starting to pattern recognition right so
then I'm like in my petulant bratty
teenager and I'm like I'm gonna go buy
my Nirvana shirt because nothing matters
you know and look being in your inner
teenager is not cute nobody wants to
fight with the person who used to think
the Spin Doctors were cool and still
kind of does going without therapy in
scientific terms it's like
it's like when you're using your dryer a
lot and you forget to clean out the lint
sorry that that looks so sexual with my
finger but you know and then you know
your dryer doesn't work as well and then
your clothes are all damp and then you
smell like swamp and someone you walk in
some someone's like is that a wharf did
a wharf just you know therapy cleans the
lint out of your brain okay gets as my
dad used to say get the shit out of your
ears the lint that tells you you should
post a bikini selfie to make an ex
jealous during work hours don't do it
therapy quite simply is like going to
the gym for your brain you work out all
the guilt the shame you release your
magical thinking you say out loud your
worst ideas of what you think you should
be doing you build the muscles of not
doing dumb things that are a negative
contribution to your future self you've
heard me say it before and I'm just
going to keep pounding this drum till
you do it y'all
um so talk to a sane person and uh you
know don't don't talk to your friends
who are self-proclaimed life coaches who
also happen to be crashing on your couch
that's not the person you should be
getting life at okay no more making
Wackadoo choices as an adult therapy
helps with this sorry there's too much
here and yeah you skipped it that's okay
well yeah I just I just wanted to cut
through it yeah
therapy is about making less Wackadoo
choices want to be less wackadoo
betterhelp.com want to be in less
pickles
betterhelp.com want to have less
emotional hum dingers unless jams
better help is your guy no more pickles
no more jams thanks betterhelp
have I told the story about Michael
Jackson in the cake on this podcast
I don't remember let's go so so I know
someone that directed Michael Jackson in
music video this must have been it was
during it was after the Naomi Campbell
one you know the famous famous one when
his videos were really not real and it
was lunch
and because I was like tell me
everything about Michael Jackson he was
like my take on Michael Jackson he was
just like a six-year-old you know they
say you are the age you are when you
became traumatized sometimes you freeze
or you freeze at the age you become
famous yes all these series I don't none
of them are scientifically backed but it
was like he's so young emotionally you
know it was like dealing with a child
who is brilliant and in a man's body and
I was like tell me more I need more and
he was like well lunch happens there's
45 minutes for lunch he goes into his
dressing room he has food delivered it's
like this big box we're like it's sushi
it's whatever Michael Jackson eats you
know what I know and um 45 minutes
passes he's still in there they really
have to like get the shot off
um this was before he caught his hair on
fire with the Pepsi commercial which I
was an extra in no yeah I was an extra
in that Pepsi commercial directed by Bob
geraldi yes wild I was an extra okay go
ahead okay I want to loop back on that
because I my now lawyer was there that
day and was like give me the the film
whatever you would say give me the reels
like because they were rolling on it was
wild yeah and so
um it's you know an hour passes an hour
and a half past they're like we gotta
get about because we gotta shoot this
thing so someone just opens the door
it's unlocked what had been delivered to
him was a sheet cake
and he had torn through the sheet cake
and in the sheet cake were little
figurines of like little like a king
cake people king cake like yeah like a
New Orleans king cake where there's a
doll inside like a traditional thing go
ahead terrific yeah um that has a full
baby in it yeah and so it was all these
little tiny figurines and he was just
playing with them
and it had been delivered in a cake wait
do we think he ate the cake or was just
going to get the figurines he was just
playing with the figurines okay they
said the cake seemed like it had just
been destroyed but not right not eaten
okay
I got to meet him one time
uh later on I was doing this thing where
I had they had to teach me to dance it
was this thing called Medusa dare to be
truthful that Julie Brown remember the
redhead Julie Brown from MTV she was
playing Madonna
no the uh the Caucasian Julie Brown with
red hair and I got to be one of the
backup dancers and I was the only person
in the backup dancers that wasn't a real
dancer so they had to give me dance
lessons because I was so bad so the girl
teaching me was this girl named Smith
wordies and she was the girl in The
Smooth Criminal where Michael does like
one dance with a girl so ironically John
Landis was shooting blood the video for
black and white right in the same studio
so I got to go the day before he was
gonna show up and the choreographer was
a guy known in Vince Patterson brilliant
guy and he did all the choreography and
he's like do you want to watch the
choreography before Michael gets here
tomorrow I was like oh my God it blew me
away it was so difficult I was thinking
how could he learn this in a day okay so
he doesn't show up the next day okay he
was and this is before internet even
much less social media it was in like
the LA Times the next day that he was at
the I'll never forget this so Random the
Westfield mall at like pico and Westwood
with
um
um Emmanuel Lewis which is very asexual
if you know what I'm saying and so
um he just like went shopping and he
came the next day and the catering
Webster yes first I thought it was a
boxer Great okay so yeah he was a boxer
that is not what asexuals do I don't
follow famous children and I don't
follow Sports so the wires crossed all
right so he um showed up the next day
and the catering was all vegan and he
did have delicious um fried tofu which I
had had Tofu for the first time and
became a convert but
um he came into the lunch area and this
girl Smith because she knew him went in
to talk to him so I got to like say hi
to him but during their conversation the
thing that blew my mind his voice was
totally low and normal he talked like
this he did it I I want to thank
everybody he was joking with her like I
intermedi was a comedian but like joking
around in like a grown-up way and
clearly she was somebody he really liked
and respected and stuff and I she was
like oh oh and I'm not saying like oh
he's super Butch and straight like I
don't whatever but I thought that was
fascinating wow and there was something
that made him make what I actually think
it was a bad decision to do that
affectation of that voice but it was
really interesting to hear him talk it's
like the first it's like when Paris
Hilton decided to do her real voice
right right I love her by the way and I
know you love her you know it's funny I
try to explain to my younger friends the
the vibe in the 90s and the odds you
almost had to live through it to even
get it wow and that the edict to
comedians was to be the most vicious
possible and look we called it roasting
yeah and it was the assignment and so I
look back on my specials or whatever and
of course like I wouldn't say half the
stuff I said then
but the only thing I defend is
we still were making fun of because I'll
do the women thing because that's what I
feel guilt about but we were making fun
of girls girls women that were
multi-multi-millionaires genetically
blessed Beauty at the time it didn't
feel like punching down no it was
punching it was the way it was punching
up I'm sorry but like if you saw the
famous Time cover of Brittany Lindsay in
Paris leaving the nightclub
Lin's you know Lindsay looked wasted in
the photo they were probably underage
whatever Club they were leaving Paris
was driving so she maybe wasn't
um wasted I don't know but and then
Brittany looked whatever out of it or
drunk or something and it's like I still
will defend my right to go hold on these
are girls that number one can certainly
afford to have drivers right like one
thing that cracked me up about that era
everybody was constantly getting trouble
because they drove themselves everywhere
right right almost like late 90s or Uber
yeah right these girls drilled
themselves and guys so you know people
Pete Davidson style running their cars
into houses getting busted for Coke all
the time but it is see Davidson he ran
his car into a house oh yeah he's so
he's stolen in haste bit yeah he took
hands back and they just picked a
different house and lived it was I mean
I was writing on a talk show during that
time last call of Carson Daley
um I'm gonna be jealous and yeah and
that was it I mean Leno Letterman all of
it it'd be like who's gonna do the
Lindsay joke tonight right he's going to
do the Paris joke and it was always like
their crotch was showing getting out of
a car it was sluts whores by the way but
it was like I'm just saying it was the
time of the thong and it was the time of
the low-rise jeans that were so low
there was the time of the sex tape that
was new that we were watching people
have sex yeah you know that were famous
right and it was like what are we gonna
not make I mean and look and I come from
a place where you know I come from a
home where I'll bust each other's balls
we do roast each other nothing's off
limits to this day yeah I mean when I
had an eating disorder as a teenager my
family joked about me and you know sort
of stuff you look like an Auschwitz
victim you look like this that like it
was like that's what we joked about
totally you didn't joke about stuff that
had nothing to do you went to the core
and we didn't realize we were you know
traumatizing someone or in retrospect
now it's punching down and I think that
comedians like you know speak for myself
or the female comic like we feel like
such losers that the idea that we're
making fun of the girls that we feel
like don't think we're cool or would
never want to hang out with us and we're
just kind of going like oh she's never
even going to hear this right and like
I'm sure she would think this is funny
or you know you don't realize like oh
what if one of these people has a
substance abuse problem no one knew
Paris had gone through some yeah in
school where she was abused that story
you know her documentary on YouTube is
really good too yeah brilliant and I
also think nobody understood the trauma
of Fame like no you didn't have the word
no one at the time was used for like ER
nurses 100. that's it and no one was
like oh this person who was born into
money or this person who's famous could
possibly be be traumatized by Fame
because we're all trying to get it but
it was always the dude that released the
tape like that's the other thing is they
these girls had to deal with then those
dudes lying and saying oh she leaked it
or she wanted it out there no and there
was no way to corroborate there was no
way for you know one of these girls to
go on IG live and like clear it up you
know if they did they weren't believed
you know yeah but I remember when I
hosted the Joan Rivers Comedy Central
Rose I remember Joan wanted me to do it
because we were Pals and I think she
thought in this Hunger Games environment
maybe you can sort of protect me and I
did get to tell a couple like sort of
heartfelt moments with her and stuff but
it was definitely weird the jokes that
were pitched to me written by dudes and
they were all dry vagina jokes and Joan
was already doing them by herself and
that's already funnier but I remember
people canceling I don't even remember
this but I always canceled last minute
uh Lily Tomlin canceled and I actually
called her up and I was like look some
of the big names are canceled that's how
I got on it no but Joan was like I don't
want all people I don't really know very
well I've been around so long and this
is before Roseanne won Q Anon but
Roseanne was still Roseanne and Roseanne
canceled and I called Lily and I said do
you think you can come like Joan kind of
really wants you to be there and and
Lily said this thing that always stuck
with me and she goes don't you think
John's been roasted enough
and I really did feel dirty doing that
roast I really did I didn't mean I
didn't know and I had no idea for me it
was like paycheck for me it was if
you're here you must want to be here I
had no clue I had no remember they know
it's an homage and Joan kept saying
afterwards she's like yeah they kept
telling me it was an honor she's like oh
yeah an honor but I remembered that Lily
saying and I thought yeah like and I to
this day I actually still think the Pam
Anderson one is fair even though she's
got a great story that we now know but
she also sort of made a character that
was a character that I I for one didn't
think she was really the girl from me
you know I think the the shadow one was
fair like I obviously I think the Trump
one was fair like there's somewhere you
go okay this person has kind of put
themselves in a situation right and some
of them just kind of didn't make sense
and I think that because I wrote for the
rose for so long and then was on them
for a while and now just rebooted them
on only fans TV but the way we did it
was like super loving that our rules
were no women are old no vagina stuff no
guys have small dicks like no you're a
pedophile if you're not actually you
know stuff like that like we had because
you know it was it's shocking to me you
know that people got hurt on these
because I'm like this is a job we're
joking I'm in the writer's room I'm
writing the jokes and I know they're not
true right you know what I mean so I'm
going oh what do we say about Lisa
Lampanelli yeah can say she's not
hilarious right and say she's not
successful she's one of my here so I
guess yeah everyone always talks she
talks about dating black guys I guess
we're doing the black guys right right
to me it was like always just like a
like a Rubik's cube of like what's the
math yeah yeah and I was too young at
the time to know like oh sometimes
people have to put themselves in
humiliating situations either to pay a
tax bill or to yeah stay relevant or at
the time because the people that sign up
to do them I feel like they became so
beloved yeah for doing it it was like
this shame release and also that it's
actually really nice the structure of
those where they got their comeback at
the end yeah and whether it was a
Shatner that was going to do written
material or a Joan that wanted to write
her own like that was always the Saving
Grace of the whole thing yeah and
luckily Joan was such a Crusher her set
really did do better than everybody's
period of course and it crushed me when
I watched her documentary piece of work
and she was like in the limousine
talking about how much she was dreading
it yeah how accumulating it was how his
female comedians you know people want to
see us you know get on and denigrated
and they don't want to see a shadow they
don't want to see us win and I was like
oh my God like it really yeah I was
embarrassed you know but that it was
like you know I did Hasselhoff after
that
um well yeah
I just I just don't think David
Hasselhoff cried for two days 100 I just
don't see that 100 I'm saying do it
feels like you know it was um yeah I
just in my head at the time it's like
Joan doesn't do anything Joan doesn't
want to do but I'm just saying like in
the 90s and odds we did not have that
sense of Hasselhoff fair this person
yeah not really yeah but it was kind of
like who's ever hot who's ever game yep
and I I think we're getting better about
that look I have to be told I don't mean
to sound like in those days but I do
have to be told sometimes like what not
to say and everything I welcome it yeah
because I don't want somebody leaving in
tears I want somebody that goes home and
goes wow I went to a comedy show to have
fun and this happened you know when we
play rough and I think that my biggest
problem with the roast at that time is
uh making a sports metaphor here
hopefully it's cracked which is you know
in MMA you would never put a heavyweight
with a featherweight yeah right and I
think that's what a lot of those roasts
end up doing yeah it's like you put Pam
Anderson with Greg Giraldo like what are
you doing like why is you know Kate
Walsh with you know uh Jeff Ross I mean
yeah he did great on whatever roast that
she did so to me it was like all killers
only yeah and then let's all get
together and go like what we do in the
green room that's all fair right never
trying to hurt each other we do it as
soon as money gets involved all of a
sudden we're like going so no it was
weird when they would throw in like
straight actors and actresses
and I always felt for them and they were
always nervous as hell as they should be
yes as they should be and I didn't at
the time I didn't know like because I
was getting paid two thousand dollars
yeah so I didn't know how much everyone
was yeah they must be making a hundred
million dollars or something a year or
they must have some deal where they can
cut things out I don't know because
having been in the writer's room at the
roast before we would write all these
jokes and then the producer would say
you can't say that you the you know the
daughter's off limits remember it was
like uh for Shatner the dead wife in the
pool was off limits for there was always
like an off limits you know for Joan it
was uh her daughter as you know yeah
yeah so it was like we had to abide by
all these rules so by the time we got
there I was kind of like oh I guess this
is all yeah above board you know but
yeah there was a lot of stuff that I
feel like you know was going on um
you're right hair you know you start
going for women they start going for
physical stuff yeah I think it always
seems a little bit rougher you know for
sure
um and like it's always like the older
you get the less sex you have it's like
yeah I don't even know what this is
you've seen the comeback
after seeing that it really made me
understand that Dynamic of what we do
yeah in this business and God has she
nailed those dramatic scenes as well
like as much as she's innately funny and
talented she that's that's show neat she
needs to be able to hit this at the end
when she does a one take of talking
about being on the field hockey team and
having the rod in her back is just you
know can I ask you um on that note yes
and we can cut this out one time I went
to your home yeah and you had speaking
of just hot slippery sex
your bed had these lucite bars on them
right and I was like that is such a cool
bed and you're like oh yeah that's for
sex I was like and I didn't I never knew
if you were serious or not I was now I
didn't build it for that but it became
that okay so I built a headboard that
this is like so 90s it was like sparkly
vinyl or some crap and there were lucide
bars so you could see through because
there was really cool wallpaper and I
just thought it would look not like a
big massive headboard but it had high
ceilings and I remember you know banging
some guy and being like Oh I could like
reach right back and so I'm not saying
there was anything weird but let's just
go straight missionary it's nice to
ground yourself yeah and please use this
yeah and by the way let's talk about sex
I don't tell you why because like I said
I'm 62 and there's like this thing going
on with my girlfriends my age where
they're saying proudly like and if I
never have sex again it'll be a Day Too
Soon me don't put me in your fucking
club yeah like I went to a girlfriend's
house and she actually made a point to
say she's gay but she said about her
partner she's like oh we have separate
rooms I mean I have been closed for
business for a long time and she's like
right I'm like no no don't write me no
no I God knows my parents never talk to
me about this but I don't know how that
even started where people think there's
like an age where you stop actually your
testosterone goes up as a woman as you
get older I don't know I'm still on a
hormone patch because I still get an
iPad night sweats but I just don't and I
don't know if that's just like an old
Trope yeah yeah that girl's bought into
sure or if it's that guys aren't
attracted to women over a certain age
but like I I don't I don't uh sign on to
that yeah I just think the laundry of
sex the better you are at it the more
you know what you want and once again
they never say that about guys yeah like
you never hear like wow you better get
him before he's 60. yeah yeah otherwise
he has clothes for business no Robert
Janeiro having a baby no how old's
Robert De Niro like 78 that's like him
being like I want to have a kid but only
for like six years yeah and that's all
he'll need like I don't wanna I don't
wanna have to raise it right you know
because once he starts drooling and the
whole thing oh I don't know if you have
this yet but I can't recommend it enough
I am in a small and I'm proud of this
but I have what's called a dementia
condo plan
okay okay so so
by the way I hate to see you you know
this is going so I I am I'm sure Canada
said no yeah after Canada said no I'm
not welcome there I'm barely welcome
here but um I was in the blue cities but
I am sort of okay so once again I did
steal this idea from dear departed Joan
Rivers because she had a dementia condo
plan with get ready Cindy Adams Barbara
Walters and Judge Judy I confirmed it
was not going into a condo she's got
three Yachts here's the thing though
they would fight over whose house they
would get even though they'd all have
dementia so they wouldn't know and Jones
said they would save money on the
caregiver and the dog walker because
they would never know who was it and
where but Barbara Walters had the Doris
Duke apartment so that has certain
cachet but Judge Judy has more money
than the almighty okay I've seen the
almighty's receipts and she doesn't come
close to Judge Judy anyway so okay
here's my my dementia condo it's a
little it's a golden hour girls just but
remember we've already we already have
dementia at this point okay so it's not
even really like we see each other or
know each other is there yeah which is
why you have to pick rich people because
you do want to be comfortable when
you're you know yeah leaking yeah yeah
and so um my dementia condo is Sia okay
yeah our usual Francia uh Khloe
Kardashian okay and Kris Jenner
I think that's solid this isn't going to
be live streamed though I feel like if
it's yeah it might be a Kardashians are
there she might I forgot the characters
are there by the way we also get hair
makeup every day like Sunnyvale
so we're laying there for the most party
mobile and we still get full Glam and I
think we should definitely live in
Chris's place because she's gonna have
you know I also think Chris will be the
last to get dementia because I think her
motor skills will remember how to print
money so she'll still her room will be
like she's gonna have the money printing
machine which I've seen I do think those
skims help with circulation to the brain
there's something going on and she
probably has like 114 of scams yeah
there's some kind of shady she doesn't
need to skimp off the door she's just
got it all we're also gonna own a church
so we can get everything tax free
remember when Katy Perry bought a church
by accident no no we're we're gonna buy
people okay we're not just buying a
building we're buying smart so this is
like Tech trafficking technically but it
is it's a church Alt
so that means Chris has enough
relationships to make like all the local
authorities look the other way yeah
although and this is really really sick
I don't know if you have this with your
guy yet but my husband who's 18 years
younger I this is so Twisted I can't
help but fantasize about his wife when I
croak because let's not kid ourselves
he's not gonna outlive me no way and so
I want him to be with Chloe I think
she's very sweet she is disgusted not
with her but with him she is I was
trying to rescue a giraffe in Malibu
during the Woolsey fires she reached out
to me before anyone
okay with a leash what does that mean
here's a lasso
all right so
um I think that Chloe and my husband
Randy would be happy okay once again I'm
basically I am here's the thing I don't
want to live that long if I go today I'm
ready honey yes this time and I oh the
other thing I'm upset about I don't know
about you because you're with child or
it's a bit but
um I am livid that I'm still alive
fucking apocalypse
it's not weird that we were chosen for
this no it's it is I'm livid about it
like I can't tell you how pissed I am
and we'll get back to the dementia dream
home soon but just know that's a solid
group yeah and um and then in LA in
California
I don't know and I don't feel like I
feel like most half my friends are
talking about the other most of my
friends are talking about bunkers
they're like there's them oh they're
already in the bunker they're looking at
Bunker look at bunkers Kentucky they're
going underground see I'm gonna be I'm
just gonna go out there one more
wildfire and I'm just gonna go out there
just naked arms up take me more today's
my big day and there's many days where I
just ask my husband to just walk me to
Point Doom and just throw me into the
water and call Chloe I said you're not
gonna find me for weeks weeks but yeah
you would just keep watching back in I
mean there's no way did it go out and so
am I I'll go to Catalina float there for
a while and so um have you made a will
of course really you know I haven't yet
and I know I'm supposed to okay I know
is that crazy okay what okay I know I
the problem is that this is very
upsetting for me well I'm okay very
upsetting sorry first of all now I have
to put you in touch with his yorman
that's how this works twist my arm okay
Susie Harmon will hook you up please
don't I'm still good friends with Susie
Orman if your readers don't remember
this is yourmon show hey girlfriend
denied right she had that show on CNBC
we're still like besties money genius
money genius she's never steered me
wrong every piece of advice she gave me
gave me I took all this other stuff you
had you leave all your money to her she
is smart which was wise
um by the way I should get her in the
dementia condo what am I thinking yeah
you should bye bye Chloe you know
bye-bye so I got to trim the fat honey
Somebody's gotta go it's not my choice
and so yes you need a living revocable
trust
and you need a plan for who can take
care of your Affairs if you become
incapacitated and anyway oh really I
think one way that real I well
um Jamie Spears
can I be your conservator okay no
Britney's Dad yeah
he's in charge like he'll give you all
the Good Meds
um but you number one have to do it so
that if something happens to you your
animals go to somebody yes that isn't
crazy yeah right and then the problem is
I still think of my will right now doing
it like as a bit that that I would do it
right I would like leave like half my
money to like an ex who yeah or
something stupid and by the way you can
be as detailed as possible you can
decide I'm gonna give my Kathy Griffin
poster and that is kind of weird you
have a giant Kathy Griffin poster yeah
is it like okay super fans
um or or you can just be like okay I'm
Gonna Leave It All To You know
ex-charity and this person but the first
thing you just have to do is you just
have to get a general one at least and
you have to decide who's your who's
who's in charge you wouldn't know the
answer to this yes what happens when
someone leaves 10 million dollars to
their cat
it goes to the person who is the
conservative of the will so if you
didn't assign a person like there's a
documentary about this called Gunther's
Millions where somebody leaves a bunch
of millions to their dog and then of
course you find out the dog's handlers
get everything because that's how it
would go so the court first of all you'd
be in Probate forever and the number of
people fighting to hit your state would
be ridiculous but chances are I know
this is crazy they the court might go
well who spent the most time with the
dog so your housekeeper will be making
out like a bandit oh I like that or
whoever is in yeah or leave it to her
yeah but that's what happens when people
leave money to an animal like when I
think um Elizabeth Taylor I thought
somebody left yeah it really it really
goes to the person and usually it's even
delegated how much they're going to give
to the maintenance of this part of the
animal's life sometimes people have it
so that if when that animal passes away
they want the person to get a new
similar like type of dog and make that
like Gunther the second you know that
sort of thing wild I know so yeah I mean
uh uh This is Wild because
um Michael Jackson actually abused his
animals really I mean he didn't the Bob
Dunn did but uh he left two million
dollars to his chimp bubbles but I
uh he it was there was more than one
bubbles there was many of them
interesting yeah because you can't keep
a chimpanzee as a pet in a suit they
would keep him in these um cages so that
they weren't able to develop muscles or
anything oh my god
um this is really interesting Oprah
Winfrey 30 million uh she was once
quoted as saying that if her home were
to catch on fire one of the personal
possessions she would grab is a photo
album of her five dogs and that she
would give 30 million to her dogs
okay that's that's high oh yeah good
time yep Pat Gunther 80 million yes
Carlotta liebenstein yeah
whoa who supposedly was nobility
although I think that's in question but
yeah there's a whole doc series about
exactly what happened to Gunther's
Millions literally millions it's called
Gunther's Millions wow yeah and so a
good went to the handlers and the
implication in the doc series is that
they were not very responsible with it
and by that I mean they straight up
started a sex cult and by the way I
always go whatever it's called but does
every call have to be a sex call I think
so I think that's to help just be no
remember the old suicide Cults see that
was something I could wrap my brain
around I just put on the Adidas sneakers
and that's it but always with the sex
culture I know remember the Nexium one
where we thought it was about volleyball
and math and then it's about sex always
I thought it was simply mind control but
always write down branding I think even
if you don't plan on it I feel like you
start a call then you're like oh there's
all these people in my house and like
they keep asking me questions I've
watched everything there is to see about
Nexium it's so great I know there's
still a couple of those gals that go and
like serenade him I have one of the tank
tops from Spirit Week what I know I'll
show it to you nice pretty wild nice
yeah Sarah Edmond Edmondson who's on it
became a friend of mine and we'd like
Matt and style yeah I mean fascinating I
love all have you seen the Duggars
docu-series no I've heard about it well
guess what they're tied to tell me the
sex calls
they're part of Christianity is a
certain sect that blah blah blah and the
minister and as you're watching it
you're like oh boy that Minister just
has that sex cult face and sure enough
like episode three they're like and
you're not gonna believe what he did
with the women like let me guess always
um can I ask you about dating younger
yes my guy is 11 years younger than me
and it is and it's nothing it's
bothering me that it usually bothers the
woman in relationships with the woman's
older
my guess is it doesn't bother him I
didn't realize how no he loves it I
didn't realize how important it was to
me to be able to have the same to be
able to sing along to the same music
yeah like it drives me nuts when I'm
like you don't know Eve like it just
makes me nuts and then I'm like we don't
understand each other like music I guess
to me feels like such a shared set of
emotions I got lucky because my husband
happens to be this weird like 80s music
junkie and so when he plays those songs
I'm like and I was there
I was alive and everything how was
seventh grade I mean it's only creepy
when you think about when I was 20. uh
like when I'm like telling him who Mitch
Hedberg was I'm just like oh this is
such a bummer right right you know you
know that's why God invented YouTube
oh yeah what about Twitter turning to X
do you think it's really gonna happen
it's supposed to happen today yeah I
think that Elon Musk will do any I mean
he's really wants to keep he what is the
was it PayPal the guy for you I'm
kidding a lot sure I would love to be
one of his handmaids oh like one of his
I don't think my eyes are fine where you
accidentally got pregnant yeah and then
you don't need to see him yeah you know
there's he I mean everybody wins yeah
he'll just put twins in you but you have
to look like an alien it seems like a
thing that's the downside you know I'm
not gonna get dreadlocks or whatever his
girlfriends need to do in order for him
to like be interested yeah yeah dating
younger there's just like a couple of
those things look the life experience
stuff is real I mean that is something
that actually took me years to get over
um and I it does take a while because
like I said our our difference is great
it's 18 years
and I think unlike a dude because I've
known many many guys with an 18 years
younger girlfriend or wife and the guys
I know that are like that are wealthy
and they really marginalize these women
like It's like because you know guys
think of me as a dude like guy comics
don't hit on me they think of me as a
dude and so I'm often the only girl in
the room with the wealthy older guy
who's successful and he can relate to me
and we're chatting but often I'm like
well you married her isn't she allowed
in this room you know and I think with
older women and younger guys that's not
the case yeah like I have no desire to
like sock my husband away somewhere
because he just can't possibly keep up
or right I assume he wouldn't be able to
contribute I think that's more of a guy
thing so I'm honestly I'm the perfect
person to talk to because we've been
together 12 and a half years he would
just be like help me yeah I think that's
where the billionaires don't let their
girlfriends in yeah and because we don't
want them to get a ride out of this
state yeah yeah and once they're gone
they're gone the good thing about dating
a younger guy is you're always like
fascinating yeah like like I told him
about Lorena Bobbitt the other day oh my
God and blew his mind Lorena who cut off
her husband's penis in a field yeah and
then he ended up doing a porn well they
sewed it back on to the best of their
ability yep and then he went on and did
a porn called John Bobbitt uncut it was
this whole or parts like strange
chilling I'm the most interesting person
alive but I just was there right you
know what I mean right so it's kind of
amazing how do you know all this right I
was like I know Michael Ohan
you know so true
um something I want to talk about and
get into as much or as little as you
want uh I am slowly admitting that I
have been struggling with an addiction
to weed and I have stopped I know
um I think something's happening where
people are starting to go like oh it's
every a lot of people are going through
this a lot of people are leading on
substances a lot of people you know I
never thought I would be someone that
would be addicted to a substance because
I was always addicted to work or also I
believe the weed pitch was it is
non-addictive
which I don't get you I'm not sure what
that's supposed to do cotton pitch too
yes from Pharmaceuticals right right
right yeah you know yeah and I couldn't
believe some of the thoughts that I was
having about did it make you paranoid or
whatever the downside yes first of all a
lot of people do really well on weed um
I know a lot of people whose personality
is a match yeah I'm already an intense
person
um I'm already you know Comics I'm
already skeptical I'm already Devil's
Advocate I'm already you know let's find
the Scientology boats person you know
I'm already I'd love to pick apart a
conspiracy theory I want to you know see
all the alien footage
um it and my mom died and I I think my
biggest mistake with it was using it to
check out instead of check-in I wasn't
like I want to be more creative I want
to go to this party and be social
because I no I remember talking to one
comedian who takes who smokes before a
show and I was like doesn't we just
knock you out wow so I thought it was
interesting and I think this comic was
using it to deal with anxiety probably
but even though it does cause anxiety
down the line because it lowers your
tolerance so if I may ask were you using
it a certain time of day were you
smoking it was it gummies it was the
gummies I tried a couple times during
the pandemic and that was not a match
for me because my brain on a gummy says
that gummy didn't kick in it didn't work
oh you need another gummy yeah yeah like
it's not it's it's it cooked weird yeah
it distributed weird right and I I don't
feel anything so you get you got more
for get or got I should say from smoking
so smoking I felt like I can control it
right does it last as long you know
gummies are kind of this like you either
doesn't hit at all or you're like on the
four or five yeah and then all of a
sudden you know going the wrong
direction yeah totally so I was like
this just isn't for me I think it's you
know a lot of people I'm sure do well on
them
um I think they just haven't figured out
the dosage yet the way if you put and I
have well I saw this like in 60 minutes
so there you go but I have heard that
for some reason weed is like way
stronger than it was in the 60s 70s
which I'm not sure how people measured
but the way that it is so much stronger
now the Edibles you know because also
you an ease driver it's the name of the
weed delivery company it's in their car
the the chocolate's Melt you don't know
how it's distributed you know and I
think that to me it was kind of boiling
down to a gambling addiction ultimately
which is the idea of like once every
four or five times it would be great I
would think of a great joke I'd have a
great Insight I'd be self-aware I would
be forgiving everybody oh my abusers
hurt people hurt people yeah I'm
breaking ancestral Cycles I'm journaling
I'm cleaning my house like I'm having
great conversations with people and then
the other three or four times I feel
like I'd be super Manic you know I'm
falling behind I'm never gonna make it
you know obsessing about some thing I
said at a Comedy Central
Premiere eight years ago this person
hates you because you said you know I
just it was like is there one thing that
made you go okay enough like was there
one night or was there one
thing where you were like I feel
depressed all the time or like and I
started losing things I don't like being
a mess I don't like not knowing where my
shit is yeah I don't like like being
putting something in the calendar on the
wrong day like I was just kind of that
person you know and I found myself um
uh
one time I did give my dog the wrong
medication and it wasn't it's not like a
super serious one yeah um but I remember
just being like that could have been bad
little things like that there was a lot
of that could have been bad yeah and
like I feel like I just got a little bit
of a yeah what about where are you on
psychedelics because I'm also in
recovery I was a prescription pill
addict I still am an addict but I'm in
recovery and you know in the big book
Bob Bill W who wrote The Big Book
um does refer to in reference I don't
remember the psychedelics but
psychedelics yeah how do you feel about
those and do you feel like you would get
relief from them or where are you with
that I took psychedelics I took
mushrooms on a live podcast once it was
so fun I loved it what it was the first
time I had done it I did LSD when I was
like 11 it was a nightmare that was like
is LSD manufactured or is it like
mushrooms
lsds it's all chemical acid which is all
chemical right so this was mushrooms the
first time I ever did them I did it live
on a podcast I felt like my brain was
supercharged yeah I felt like I could
see clearly I felt like I was funny I
was having a good time who knows maybe I
didn't read the room like you know wait
did you then watch it
I thought it was funny so you thought it
was okay oh my God and then I got home
and watched it like it was okay rain was
moving fast you were genuinely having
fun and it and it reflected in the show
it wasn't like I felt like I was present
delusional enjoying yourself being mean
or anything right so you didn't look
like a sloppy drunk you were just fun
and footloose and fancy for you okay I
think so I mean I'm always are you Pro
mushroom now not yet it actually
energized me a lot uh made me think like
today's the day that we're gonna clean
up the water in West Virginia not that
that doesn't need to be done right now
right today's the day that that I'm
gonna make sure that Pearl Tatton a
woman that stood up at a slave auction
in West Virginia uh you know and died
for we're gonna make a movie about her
and get her the Justice she deserves it
made me very obsessed with Justice and
what is right and I think I already have
a lot of compassion I already have a lot
of empathy and I think a lot of people
take it to have compassion and empathy
so it kind of supercharged that and made
me you know I said it before you know on
last week's podcast like I scheduled a
call with the maritime lawyer to try to
figure out where the Scientology boats
are yeah you know yeah I was like you
know so I'm like is does someone need to
do that maybe does it need to be me
probably not you know how does one find
a maritime lawyer who did I ask uh so
did you ask the ocean I the orcas came
up ran my boat and then gave me a little
piece of paper you know so I found
myself getting very obsessed with what
is right yeah and and it wasn't a
self-righteousness it was just a I'm
gonna be the hero that does this and um
I'm already a person that you know
rescues dangerous animals and puts
myself in really dangerous situations
and I was putting myself in very
dangerous situations I felt Invincible I
felt like I had nothing to lose
um and I was doing it to try to numb
myself which you would normally do with
a prescription drug but that's not what
that drug does I think it actually makes
you more sensitive I think it makes you
more conscious I see and I was trying to
do the opposite yeah I also
um perhaps you know other people have
experienced this I think a lot of people
take mushrooms to feel compassion to
soften
or feel feelings you don't normally feel
being vulnerable whatever I don't
normally feel angered and I had anger
start coming out interesting and
interesting I didn't aim it towards
anybody but I I and my parents would
just die but I finally felt like to be
like I'm pissed at I'm mad and I think I
needed to feel that and I you know but I
was instead of just crying or grieving
or processing or talking to a therapist
I was like oh this is medicine it's
plants and you know and then you lose
track you're doing a little mushrooms
and you're smoking weed to go to bed and
then you're you know
and then the a big part of it that I
think a lot of people don't talk about
is that you don't get the quality REM
sleep where you're really processing
your subconscious stuff so on wheat or
mushrooms weed okay I would smoke some
Indica to go to bed and then you wake up
eight hours later just black hole of
nothing and now that I'm off everything
I'm having these really intense dreams
nightmares night terrors fine but at
least it's like working out the
subconscious stuff you know so I think I
was using it to check out and for the
people that use it to heal I think
that's super awesome but that's not how
and what about ketamine the ketamine uh
drip I've never done and I think
ketamine is all manufactured
Patrick I believe so okay okay people
think I'm like an authority on ketamine
because I during the pandemic I did a
micro dose of
oxytocin and ketamine it's a nasal spray
a lot of people it is highly addictive
um
what's oxytocin oxytocin is what you
feel the love chemical when you hug
someone when you have an orgasm when you
see your baby for the first time so the
idea of it is like the Forgiveness
formula so the idea is like a little bit
of ketamine a little bit oxytocin you
get on with a therapist and then you you
take it and then you start going okay
this person that abused me I can forgive
them I forgive you you forgive me now is
that as radical as one I've had friends
talk about a guided Journey
a guided journey is that when there's a
drip and I think I think that's the drip
like the IV infusion
a lot of people said Neil Brennan has
talked about this publicly about how
much it transformed his life a lot of
people talk about uh you know friends of
mine that have gone through serious like
acute trauma like their husband gets hit
by a car and is just dead the next day
they have two kids you go straight to
this place ketamine in your and it helps
you to be able to not want to blow your
head off yeah kind of thing I want to
save that for later yeah
this is how much of an addict I am I
want to save drugs for what I know I'm
really how much for the dementia dream
condo yeah exactly
I've never done heroin I've never done
cocaine I'm never done let's do it for
sure when I'm at the condo it's heroin
there's um I mean there's some Professor
that micro doses heroin uh and if you
don't have an addictive personality and
can do that that's awesome I just think
that is it Professor Timothy Leary
because I don't know if he was honest
about all that but I think that the same
way that we sort of you know watch Mad
Men and we're like remember when they
would just have a three martini and
they're like yeah I'm just having a
drink it's like I think we're kind of
doing the same thing we're using words
like plant medicine I'm sure it's got
medicinal qualities but if you're not
for me like the ketamine nasal spray
works because I was working with a
doctor I was gone with a therapist there
was like a goal of we're doing step work
like we're you know
um uh basically dislodging these
crystallized resentments like we're
melting the stuff that's poison we're
drinking poison waiting for the other
person to die how do we forgive these
people not because they deserve
forgiveness because we deserve peace
yeah that was the part of program I just
couldn't and I think my body wanted to
stay in uh don't forgive this person to
keep myself safe and then this helped me
go like you're safe you don't have to be
mad at this person that hurt you 20
years ago and keep punishing everybody
else and living at this war mentality
you know I think I just had this
mentality when you say person do you
mean Ellen don't
I'm kidding why can't I make a innocent
joke you can dude I'm the only person
that makes jokes about Ellen oh thank
God do I not make jokes about Ellen
every episode whatever's like everyone
just like goes under the table I'm like
we're still scared of Alex yes this is
wild today we are yes people are like
Ellen was mean I'm like she used to make
her staff crouch in a box for 40 minutes
she's killed people to that I'm almost
sure I'm not positive but I'm pretty
sure all right back to the pot now have
you found it difficult to stop or do you
taper or what you know it's interesting
the the reason I think it was so
difficult for me to stop is that the
damage I did when I was you know smoking
a lot of weed and by damage I mean
letting people you know maybe back in
that were tricky or you know being late
on a deadline I then was like well I
need to smoke weed to just cope with
this so that I can stop smoking weed
yeah that's what the that's what
addiction does to you your addiction's
like if I could just smoke a little weed
I can see this problem right I can solve
this weed problem this pesky weed
problem and then you're like the problem
was it was Vapes now if I just I just
need to pre-roll yeah and then you're
like that wasn't the right pre-roll oh
it shouldn't have tasted like Pop-Tarts
let me just do the adult like so there
was the whack-a-mole you know and it's
also like wheat is fun you know it might
not have been fun for Pat when we were
like editing and I I think it's fun it
made me be like let's just do this crazy
thing we're getting secondhand high
is that real does that really like if
you're next to someone smoking yeah
you're really gonna feel a buzz really
see I've never felt that huh that I know
of it's hard to get me my guess is your
brain is hard to get high too yes my
brain is hard Sledgehammer people will
see me I remember Grace would be in here
and she'd see me like smoking a pre-roll
she'd be like how are you standing up so
I think I metabolize weed very quickly
but then when it hits it hits and then I
felt like long term my brain was slower
so I think to talk about a real Rock
Bottom for people like us to perform or
I'll speak for myself was like going on
podcasts and like being my brain brain
being slower ah and not being as funny
as I know you're capable of you miss it
and I was like what am I doing yeah why
am I making myself Dumber was there an
amount per day that you're like okay
this is too much because I know gummies
is grams I don't know how the smoke
stuff is measured the smoke stuff I kind
of would I'd get them in these there's
great um The Promise is different every
time if you haven't eaten enough if you
haven't drank enough if you didn't sleep
enough the night before depending on
what you're doing you know I couldn't
get a consistent
um uh results like a measurement on this
will get me this high and then I'm like
I'm figuring it out I'm doing research
make sure to have peanut butter and
jelly sandwich where's my Pell Grants
and you're like what I've seen in all my
friends struggling to stop drinking
alcohol and they're like you know I'm
just gonna do rose yeah I'm not gonna
I'm gonna put water in my drink yeah
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna cut it with
some I'm not gonna drink till seven no
more brown liquor maybe ten yeah um can
I ask about the prescription drug stuff
yes did that just was it like a slow
burn this is so pitiful okay so first of
all
I know it's gonna sound cliche that I'm
blaming everything but honestly it
really did like start with the Trump
thing which was six years ago six long
years ago and
first of all nobody I I like really
started abusing prescription pills at
like 56. which is so old like late in
life it's ridiculous
but I will say
this is what was really twisted
I would be given pills like occasionally
for real stuff
and I remember when I was way back on
like my life on the d-list they would
have that like shady scent doctor that
would give you like that fakey bucket
physical before each season to clear you
and I remember that guy introducing me
to something called provigil which is
kind of an alternative to Adderall it's
speed and I was like what's this and he
said well I'm going to give you I think
he gave me like Valium and he said this
is to sleep and then he said this pill
we call a 10 a.m meeting pill because if
you're groggy from the Valium and you
have a meeting at 10 A.M this will make
sure your peppy and and um you know Wide
Awake provisional most often used to
treat excessive sleepiness caused by you
are the least sleepy person oh I know
it's actually used for people that have
sleep apnea but was invented 52 bomber
Pilots
not actresses okay and comedians so but
he would give me those like every year
every six months or whatever and I
remember storing them in my I had this
massive safe and I don't know why but
when I think back it was like that must
have been my addict in training
interesting remember back in the day
you'd get 90 Vicodin from a doctor from
having a broken nail 90 oxy I didn't do
a lot of oxy because Vicodin was more my
era for some reason my drug era I A lot
of people are not getting out from under
these prescription medications I mean
it's one of the biggest problems in our
country right now thank God it was
prescription and not I mean no I think
synonymous because I when I overdose
because I tried to take my life and I
wrote my husband a note and it was awful
and I have tremendous guilt about that
and I actually had to read a lot about
you said sorry you're just too old for
me I said call Chloe now
um and I I honestly was so selfish in my
addiction that well the cloud the cliche
thing I thought his life would be better
and easier Etc but I had to read up
later and I had a really smart doctor
say you know there's a lot of research
on what happens to the Survivor of
suicide especially when it's you know a
parent and a child or a marriage which
in our case is both but he's a little
younger no but um that was something
that I I learned through recovery
because I just was kind of still
thinking like well maybe it would have
been better you know and I had to learn
so much it would have been better for
him if you were gone yeah I and I
thought I've had a good run I've had a
good life I've done the stuff I kind of
want to do like he's like I needed to
update the will first I need you like
the living room just tight let me tell
you it is tight I'm gonna give a lot to
your dog though in fact Millions I'm
gonna give your dog millions and not to
his Handler I mean I'm gonna make sure
it goes right in his mouth and so I was
very fortunate that she found me a
recovery Helper because it was during
vid and they were 12-step based and I
luckily had enough friends in 12 step
that I knew it wasn't scary and I knew
there wasn't a leader so there was never
going to be like a Joel Osteen like one
like some mega church leader and uh I
knew it was free yep so I knew it wasn't
going to be a thing like well like a
Scientology pay this much you get the
next level of recovery and I think those
are the two saving Graces of AA and um I
you know what met the per the person who
who came to my house for four months
every single day piss tested me I mean
seven days a week this person was an
angel and this is when you attempted
yeah so I was on a psych hold like
Britney so I was on a 5150 psych hold
and uh did someone find you like yes I
was I wasn't able to kill myself and the
bad thing is I thought I took enough to
die and I took enough to be so groggy I
walked out of the bedroom and then I
fell down the stairs so I didn't even
throw to the cell I just fell you know
and so
but anyway
um
and so I then called a couple doctors
who were Silly enough to give me their
cell phone number and then I just came
clean and I said look I took like 100
benzos and I tried to take my life but
all that happened was I think I have
some injuries that probably should get
x-rayed because I guess I'm gonna live
now and so I went and when you're honest
and you go to the ER and you tell them
what you took and that you wrote a note
and why you're here they put you on a
cycled and so I was under lock and key
for 72 hours why do you think you were
honest in that moment like do you think
it just some it didn't even occur to me
yeah I don't know why but like one of
the doctors I actually knew pretty well
and the other doctor I had never seen
outside her office but I trusted her so
the first guy I was like well I know
this guy well enough to just be honest
Dr Drew it's Dr Drew Pinsky and he's in
my car waiting for me and so um the
other doctor I Leah it was so it did I
didn't know that you could be put on a
psych hold if you said that stuff uh I
will say in retrospect it was a rough
three days man it was a long three days
and I was in I was at Cedars and I was
already upset I wasn't in like the
Beyonce suite and I remember
looking up and there was a Dust Bunny on
like the lighting fixture and I remember
legit thinking I have got to call the
concierge
because they've got to get Consuela up
here for somebody by the way that's from
Marcus Welby MD but anyway
um and legit thinking I could like call
like to the front desk you know and the
best part is the woman they had watching
me I legit thought she was like an
enthusiastic nurse
and I would continually say to her and
God love her she never corrected me
Arlene you can you can go you've been
sitting here for like hours and I didn't
know like there were there was a 12 hour
Eileen and then there was a 12 hour Lisa
and that's what they did and I also one
time just tried to leave and did not
know the doors are locked from the
outside
so I was like click click
um
excuse me when you got up to leave what
were you where are you going I was gonna
go home and just you know fix it myself
yeah and so yeah and so I got hooked up
with AAA people that day and we I went
to like three Zoom meetings a day I
still do Zoom meetings I love it I have
a home meeting and then I have another
meeting I do twice a week and I just I
can't I know I'm sounding like well
culty but it's not a call don't be
afraid and what what did your brain
resist anything when I first went into
no I have to say I once I had bottomed
out that bad or I was on a cycled I went
I'm done yeah I also like I said I was
60. no wait 59 I was 59. so I'm like
what am I doing well like I said who
becomes a junkie at what 56 and then at
59 like wants to be like playing around
with that crap but when you look back
because I go how could I get addicted to
something right you know that like what
happened to me you know six months ago
or it was you know brewing and I'm like
me substances it's like out of nowhere
and then I look back and I'm like uh
well there was the food and then there
was online shopping and yeah food issues
man I have managers
building towards this for a while yeah I
had I mean look my man issues were my
20s and 30s for sure my food issues I
just I told you earlier started very
very young and that stuff that I
kind of felt like wasn't an issue
anymore so there was maybe a little time
between the food issues kind of
subsiding
and the pills kicking in so I think that
fooled me into thinking I'm not just
doing whack-a-mole or I'm not just
transferring minute to minute to minute
but yeah I look I I've I don't know if I
have a comedy addiction but I my
instinct I remember when I did a 50 City
Tour I remember thinking I'm gonna do 80
next year just just do it if I can you
know and then Megan some of those gigs
like I am just exhausted I do not know
why I thought this was a thing no one
asked me to do 80 cities this was all my
idea and when someone you know how do
you know when you're addicted what helps
me is number one when it makes your life
unmanageable number two when it stops
being a choice yeah and number three
when it stops being fun yeah so when I
was doing that kind of touring I was
like this is the most fun thing in the
world to me yeah and it's not fun right
now it feels it stops feeling like a
choice and I'm like oh this that's when
it's defined as addiction like I went to
a Workaholics Anonymous meeting uh once
everyone was late oh my God they're busy
everyone was late and of course it was
all people that were kind of known in
our business and we all got in trouble
because the first thing you say is Kathy
I love your work yeah you're not allowed
to say work good you're not allowed to
reward that's cool for it but the way
that people would talk about there was
one woman who was addicted to
scrapbooking and she would wake up in
the middle of the night and be
scrapbooking and she would have to
cancel things and she missed her
daughter's wedding because she's
scrapped but you know yeah and so I was
like and it sounds ridiculous but then
someone goes oh you're addicted to you
know making drunk people laugh like why
are you driving into The Comedy Store on
a Tuesday night at midnight you don't
need to do so right it really I mean I
was the shopping thing got me yeah uh
definitely over the pandemic the online
shopping thing was it clothing or was it
house stuff or what was it well moving
into a house and then that justifies it
you're like I need to fill this wall and
yeah to fill this thing and I need you
know and then I think that because the
way that my previous addictions helped
me justify my future ones where I was
like oh I've always had body image stuff
and I'm finally in a healthy weight so I
need to buy new clothes yeah you know so
they fit because if I try on something
that's small from when I was starving
myself this is going to trigger me I
just had every excuse in the book yeah I
never spend money on stuff like this I'm
always taking care of other people never
myself you know and then buying stuff
for other people was a big thing well
just this person's birthday is coming up
you have to get them six different pairs
of cowboy boots because they said they
like horses I just was like it was just
the dopamine rush it was just the and
then the shame head of when you get it
and you realize oh God I spent more
money than I need to on This I Gotta
return it you know it was just any way
to stay out of having to think about
feel my feelings yeah anyway a lot of
girls in my meetings have the shopping
thing it's very common for women to have
that particular cross shelf crossover
and I would say
pretty much all of us have food issues
yep like my I remember my sponsor saying
don't worry about talking about food
issues in a meeting because pretty much
every other girl and she goes and by
pretty much I mean every other girl has
it too so I wonder what the what the Bro
one is the the bro like what's the guy I
think guys have it now too I mean bless
their heart the guys that are keto and
they're only eating three jalapenos
there's only protein I'll only have this
protein powder they have to be built up
to this measurement of my biceps I think
guys have just morphine now too and you
guys have I went to dinner with a guy
remember this was like I was dating like
a year ago and and have a packet of
protein and put it I'm like what are
like and he's gotta he can't have water
with his food and there's no salt and
he's measuring stuff and I'm like that's
that you know in the CrossFit and the
you know I've turned into two and this
is also late in life you can laugh I've
like turned into a tick tock addict
Twitter has become so toxic yeah and
Twitter is just so much like hate it
feels like being on C-Span it's just
like dorks Dorking yeah yeah and I need
a color I need a dance can you say it
while you're dancing right I know but I
I have to say I find Tick Tock much more
calming because my algorithm is so dorky
it's puppy videos
um oh I have some puppy videos and then
there's the puppy video like I can watch
dog videos I also this is
really like racist of me to say I Can't
Get Enough Karen videos
I want to see one in the wild I have not
seen my first in person Karen yet by the
way I'll go to jail because I'll be like
the one that wants to fight Karen but I
I the stuff that you need to spend more
time in Trader Joe's Kathy I will help
you find the characters
yeah yeah and so um I I I love doing my
Tick Tock but I I'm shocked at how I'm
not 12 and yet I'm on Tick Tock a lot I
think you're the majority is not just 12
year olds anymore I know I know it's the
Chinese government and I know they have
scans of my face and they you know I
know I know I know I know yeah the other
day I logged in and it said like uh
agree to the new terms of service and I
couldn't even get to them yeah it's like
am I a crisper baby now yeah you can
there's no way the terms of services
that are just taking our face if you
guys make a robot of me can you at least
make it not a Karen right right if
you're using my family what AI Cappy
comes out just don't ever even know the
word Trump just have her in my new show
I'm so excited I didn't mean to do this
I don't even mention Trump once that's
awesome it just doesn't come up no it's
kind of been there done that no need and
I just have a shit on my mind and so I
hope no one's disappointed but like I'm
sure they'll be refreshed I just think
it's when people bring it up now on
stage there's like a uh what hasn't been
said yeah what hasn't been seen nothing
you know but anyway I that's my that's
my fear is that AI Kathy will like get
more heads and there'll be more you know
and I'm just like no well I have ai
Kathy do other topics I also think that
Tick Tock makes you realize the the
lizard brain we're up against because it
is the pavlovian it's the Skinner box I
mean it's like there are these videos is
it a cake and it's just a dog lying
there and then you see someone take a
knife to it you're like yeah and then
it's a cake and you're like yeah I know
it's adrenaline like no I'm terrified
because there was a cat abuse video
going found on Twitter and people kept
posting about it and I thought if I
accidentally even see one frame of this
thing I'm in bed for a month no I'm I
don't know a lot me too I'm so sensitive
that's like a lot of people send me
these horse videos they're like this is
so cute it's normally abused and people
just don't know it you know so a lot of
the animal videos really like stress me
out yeah I can't I yeah I and I feel
like a bad animal Advocate because I
feel like I should watch this whole
video so I can do something
and a lot of times it's their rescue
story yeah and I I just feel guilt about
it but I I am like click get me out of
here because I do not recover from that
I don't know me too what is that we're
sensitive people look the good thing is
we are already rescuing animals and we
will continue to yeah and support
organizations that do and so I kind of
like all right in that case I'm gonna
move on because I I just can't well I
could talk to you forever I could talk
to you for into the sunset and like you
are so like Breezy and grounded and
present and I love you because you're so
smart and funny you're not just funny
you're super smart and funny oh gosh I
don't feel that way but thank you for
saying that's okay I do being pregnant
makes you a moron
like I'm dumb that is not the case no
I'm a dumb person you were pretty smart
that's very nice of you to say I try to
bring Kathy's on you try to just get out
of her way oh yeah thank you so much for
coming on super awkwardly but everyone
get tickets barrage October 6 Kathy
Griffin use me as your excuse to go to
Vegas use me let's do it there's a big
Globe there now yeah and you know that
in Vegas all the homeless people live
underground in the tunnel so you don't
have to see them yeah yeah they're
called the mole people yeah I know I've
seen you know Google that I I have seen
I still watch intervention can I still
watch intervention I love you don't
write I love it it's Kathy Griffin I
love you
foreign
[Music]